Olivia was known for her big mouth
this doesn't mean really anything to me
and her literal big mouth on The
Bachelor that mouth even has its own
Twitter account the news anchors harsh
delivery made her largely hated in the
house I caught up with Olivia to talk
about her unforgettable season we're not
all gonna get along there's just no way
so many people did critique you on the
show what would you say to those people
out there who have tweeted some of that
stuff at you or message on social media
don't be mean behind the screen there
were some people on Twitter who said you
know she's a news anchor she's just
going on this show to further her career
what would you say to those people I I
can't help what I do and what I'm good
at and yeah I'm more hungry than ever to
get back to work but you know I I was I
gave it my all to bet and I'm you know
now I'm getting back to my life which is
my job but olivia has not returned to
her old job she told me she is looking
for her next move would you appear in
one of the bachelor bachelorette
franchises again not in that room I
would do like a cooking show or
something she's also not dating anyone
of course things ended in dramatic
fashion on the show though Olivia was
convinced she and Ben connected he left
her alone on an island how do you think
you guys ended up on such different
pages about what your feelings for each
other were well I think I think in
Mexico City when the girls are some of
the girls talked about me that planted a
seed in his mind that he couldn't get
past and I kept trying to move forward
but I don't think he ever good so you
know it was hard for me to watch if you
had one moment that you could do over
again from the show what moment would
that be I think I just would have shut
my mouth in Mexico City with Amanda
Olivia and that amazing mouth never
forget
you